I'd go to stop lights and I'd throw C4
on people's cars that I'm shooting
I'm starting a I'm starting to scene so
here here's something you can
around with so the cab drivers always
get pissed if you kick a cab driver's
door like kick a couple doors at a red
light and then jump on top of a car you
get them all to punch each other and
then they start a giant brawl in the
middle of the street turn and they're
like hey you you know and then they
start fighting and then you can call the
cops so you call 911 if you're playing
GTA 4 or GTA 5 right there a fight the
cop show up and then either they run and
they chase them or they pull out guns
and it's like a crazy ass shootout have
you ever gotten in the cop car and done
the done the missions and only once
or hold on hold on hold on what are we
doing let's start the show and continue
from this hold on cop car start the
mission let's go ready what let's start
what are we doing we got a bong rip in
that's what it that's what it okay okay
here we go one two imagine imagine music
boom hey what's up guys dop as Yol here
I hope you're having a dope ass day told
you can